highway bts and it is a great honor to
be invited to the white house today to
discuss the important issues of
anti-asian hate crimes asian inclusion
and diversity bts speaks at the white
house press briefing leading up to the
k-pop super group's meeting with
president biden on tuesday we hope today
is one step forward to respecting and
understanding each and every one as a
valuable person bts's appearance
coincides with the end of asian american
pacific islander heritage month through
a translator they speak out against the
surge in hate crimes towards their
community jun said today is the last day
of the aa nhpi heritage month we joined
the white house to stand with the aan
hpi community and to celebrate
jimmy said we were devastated by the
recent surge of hate crimes including
asian-american hate crimes to put a stop
on this and support the cause we'd like
to take this opportunity to voice
ourselves once again bts also takes a
moment to thank their beloved fan base
and to celebrate the diversity of their
supporters across the globe joe said we
are here today thanks to our army our
fans worldwide who have different
nationalities and cultures and use
different languages we are truly and
always grateful
chumbuk said we still feel surprised
that music created by south korean
artists reaches so many people around
the world transcending languages and
cultural barriers we believe music is
always an amazing and wonderful unifier
of all things bts leader rm ends the
appearance by expressing their gratitude
for being invited to use the white
house's platform lastly we thank
president biden and the white house for
giving this important opportunity to
speak about the important causes remind
ourselves of what we can do as artists
once again thank you very much
and this echoes bts's comments to et
last year where they continued sharing
messages of support for the aapi
community you released a statement
condemning racism and violence against
asians what message do you want
to tell to your fans or how do you want
your fans to be able to help spread
awareness
[Music]
questions
[Music]
you